this is so cool I love doing stand-up
although I will say as far as performing
goes a most envious of theater actors
because they get to bow at the end of a
performance like I can't do that
four minutes from now when I'm done here
even if we go it's great you're gonna be
like this guy's a dick he's taking a
bath I'm gonna say thank you and I'm
gonna kind of meander off the stage
that's what comedians do we slink you
know but theater theater actors they
don't say thank you right they say
you're welcome and it's here and it's
there did you enjoy the show do you like
it doesn't matter I'm gonna go ahead I'm
gonna do it again
let's say good night but actually I'm
gonna jog back in and I'm gonna do it
one more time and they do that whether
or not the play was any good measure the
audacity of bowing for five minutes
after a terrible play it's like the chef
at Panda Express coming out just shaking
everyone's hand
everybody liking the Beijing beat today
you're gonna have diarrhea for a week so
the thing about acting is you don't
actually have to be good at anything you
just have to look like you're good at
the thing that you're pretending to do
that you don't actually know how to do
for example I don't like sports I I
don't even understand them football I
don't know what's going on there but I
look like I could be a quarterback on a
CW show right and I don't know what a
quarterback does but I know how to look
like I know what a quarterback is doing
right so first thing first thing the
quarterback does is they they drive
they're dragging out lick I don't know
why they're gonna make hitman they're
huge they're gonna lay hidden under here
and then this foot goes back which
signals to that guy hey get over there
we don't have much time
right so insecure there hey good over
there within a much time and then it's
hey you keep an eye on him because he's
gonna tackle you at some point right so
it's here it's there hey get over there
we don't have much time you keep an eye
on him because he's gonna tackle you at
some point then you gotta yell a city
Wow
I'm out guys get over here
we talked about this I wrote everything
down on my forearm you know and then
when the play is in motion the
quarterback will always get tackled from
behind right so cuz he's never knows
he's gonna get tackled because I
goddammit I didn't expect to get tap not
today anyway so we do is you set all of
that to a soundtrack and that is acting
allow me to demonstrate if I could just
get a little music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys